am notebook erhalt nur noch weg er hat
alles als direkt geplant direkt
gewandhauses kids sondern willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute zum
aller ersten mal ein tolles turnier und
zwar nicht nicht mit irgendjemandem
sondern mit dem kart karten zeigen und
wir spielen super six turnier also ich
und kabel im team gegen andere
zweierteams wird sagen wir sehen uns
wieder wenn das turnier läuft gold oder
silber die geschichte geht los los geht
der hase und im stream hat das ganz gut
geklappt als im spiel von den linken
okay okay okay ist damit also prospekt
wenig jetzt kommt der chrome auf mich
dass ich den schwung in das spiel gehen
die wgb usa gehabt aber es geht ja es
ist auch sehr schön direkt nächsten noch
nicht wusste wie sind es ein wahrer
themen leute vergesst nicht ist wäre
wichtig ist zu wissen ob jetzt hier auf
schnee muss man aufpassen clara strange
bisschen im kreuzfeuer
links der linken wieder schneien kriegst
du denkst auch miami behält sich selbst
eine simple aber das geht ab ebenfalls
knapp werden muss man hat aber schon
direkt
ok ich werde mal kurz ich kann mich mal
kurz und schon ist das schon okay so
[ __ ] [ __ ] wartete post beim plötzlich
muss ich hab ein bisschen dreckig geht
noch weiter die kombos okay dann macht
ihr euch auf einer kerze lässt sich auch
sehr schön sie so perry wir spielen
super und ich würde sagen ich hatte
einfach die sequenzen zwischen kämpfen
raus so dass wir jetzt direkt zum
nächsten kampf springen ja wir sind
weiterhin en neits die man auf jeden
fall krass jetzt krieg ist dabei stärker
denn nun so leiter naja ich kann auch
nicht gegen gibt noch ein aspekt kann
ich in seiner jetzt geht es einfach
nicht
alter schwede
er schreibt ja auch noch wie frisch man
sein comeback er halt nur noch weg er
hat alles also direkt gebannt direkt
gewandt alter schwede lotter fragt man
was das für ne scheiße
diese nutzten krippenalter rieselt
draußen ja aber wie das lasst es heute
wohl müssen reporten so leute nach dem
jetzt hier scheinbar auf timo bisschen
zuviel gehackt wird spielen jetzt
einfach noch ein paar brötchen ksg
aufgabe hat würde direkt mal mitgezogen
der karthagische 1 gigawatt
wie viel geben auf einer festplatte 1 gb
sieht schlecht aus ist ziehen wir sind
in teams verboten
ja klar
richtig so wenn ich den film nicht sehen
damit da müssen sie jetzt anders machen
ich habe ein kind denn eisenstadt hatte
jetzt hab jetzt weil ich gleich weil
mich leute folgen
okay aber ich hab mal alles wird der wir
können gleich nochmal ne teams erlaubten
habe die runde gehen halte aber ich
verspreche dir alter nicht ich am anfang
so direkt um dich geschlagen und hole
mir die kills würde ich sagen ja ich
habe das als ich vom ersten geholt habe
ich gott hast du scheiße man komponenten
noch einer oper destination holla die
waldfee ist die kümmern sich einander
perfekt noch 1 2 getroffen
einfach mal rein gedreht okay gut heißt
für mich dass es nicht um hatte eine
andere gekrönt naja und zum anderen eine
waffe geschlagen
das werde ich jetzt machen ohne pfeiler
ich weiß es nicht
roche kommt macht es einem vorkommt
gegen michael ii um deine seele ist sehr
schön
helium seine seele warum deswegen hat er
nicht geschafft okay leute
wir gucken ob wir noch eine runde tsg
bekommen würde ich sagen
noch eine runde es geht es relativ leer
wo ist da die unser teamwork
also ich hab kein schmerz ich hab' ich
habe schließlich kann er stoppen
okay du hast was ich da alles klar
dann folgten wir gucken wir was gibt's
hier bisschen rüstung ich habe an als
sie ist einiges also ich kenne sap
enterprise support sehr schön als large
spd ist noch 1 1 auf noch ein
entspanntes zwei bögen drop aids als ob
es falsch wäre da hat snoop dogg doch
mein song gemacht doppeltops es wäre
doppel sollte das heißt wenn die teams
in der krippe
wer bist du so bist du bist hier daneben
wohnt einfach von hinten attackiert
attackiert in der tat bringt all
beziehen dazu bei die wachstumsphasen
der haarwurzeln wieder zu verlängern
ok-mitglied shelter schön
okay vielleicht noch ein stein natürlich
ich würde mal sagen ich werde
wahrscheinlich gebannt weil ich den
hacker bisschen beleidigt habe aber
leute wenigstens real bleibt immerhin
mal gucken was passiert wenn sitcom
stunde erwarte ich oder os bisschen oben
kisten endlager ist nichts mehr alles
gelehrt als wäre meine weltraum
persönlichkeit abgepumpt worden oder
nein als wäre sie wie kann man menschen
lernen ja oft sehr urlaub
was genau heißt es wieder keine auftrag
hier ne bis über namen reden warum wohnt
in darmstadt ist eine kleinstadt
schlicht kenne sie sehr gut
okay bekommen wir uns zurück zu tun ist
okay ich kann aber nicht so schlecht wie
es gibt auch ein anderer habe ich mir
den anderen diana
er hat auf jeden fall relativ gutes
equipment nicht so easy peasy klatschen
habe ich geführt
auf dame kommt von hinten oft sind die
roaming kosten tragen kannst du kurz für
mich einen stillen hätten sich
aufgemacht weil die runde vorbei ist die
sich darin einig habe er das war kein
team dem sich gegenseitig fertig zu
machen wir auch die opfer habe mich vor
nicht gewinne ist okay leute wären die
folge gefordert lasst gerne dauern da
geboren hat thet karten ab der ist ganz
oben in der beschreibung verlinkt
eigentlich angeles ist mein team partner
infrarot drive rts noch nicht wusstet ok
hause reise macht's gut und bis zum
nächsten video